we are now going to start off with a
nice little treat we got Filipino champ
and Combofiend
about to play an exhibition for you
right now gonna show off maybe some
characters you haven't seen before but
definitely gonna be interesting all of
you guys make sure you stay tuned it's
going down right here right now share it
with your friends let them know you guys
have been talking about how you want
more announcements you want more
information you want to see where the
theme well guess what you asked and it
is being delivered I get my spinal cord
shows up when I see guys like combo me
on the stage I cannot wait if it's
possible we've got good more on combo
fields first time I am seeing Kamal
right here ladies in action whoo she
looks pretty ridiculous already look at
this this is a little taste of some
higher level players you cannot have you
may already know Filipino champ at some
time with the game around see oh
this guy is pretty familiar with how the
metal works however this is combo beat
he might know a good thing or two about
this to take him so watching him play
you're definitely gonna get my deal of
the capabilities of his hand learn to
look at this all right so we've got
swords and Gomorrah oh nice slice we'll
get them out of here okay yeah looking
quick look very swift nice a Greg can
you get a conversion here oh it looks
like you can for one oh that was so
dirty
overhead tag goal oh oh my goodness they
already see the funky capabilities we're
gonna be seeing with this game but
layers okay okay I see you champ
get them loops so here we go super
powering up Captain Marvel also making
good use in the reality stone confirmed
I love your use of guns and swords I'm
always I know I know I do I'm actually
curious to know how our super looks like
yeah seriously okay here's the hit from
that champ
into that throw good damage
danger zone Gomorrah Finiti sorry man
activated flinging up with that super
into the tag well respect all that and
Ryan blocked it first try are you
serious these guys these guys definitely
ass event I don't I don't want to speak
about the obvious but from what I'm
seeing
that's a little more pretty you know we
just gotta throw that out there
definitely I like that okay she went
back to the may part but you don't fix
it up a little bit I like what I'm
seeing
okay my god good Morial looks so sick
I'm seeing some interesting durability
properties on those gunshots especially
against the reality songs all reflected
the reality projectile with that push
cart and went in I'm in love y'all I'm
not gonna lie this looks very weird
seeing Filipino champ with a Mega Man
they put that with a mega medics kept
all uses those two bars to kill that
combo very nice and this game you do
have access to wasting two bars using
two bars to save your partner for
potential danger well we gotta tag out
what's the comp oh okay go on for the
low all right
look like a Filipino chat messed up
throwing some layers out there for the
tag but one thing I like about the power
gym you can actually use it as an
anti-air so if you see guys that are
continuously trying to just jump on you
and maul you with air - character stuff
like that you could use the power scope
for the anti-air and just bounce around
okay they're definitely showing us a lot
of options with these characters alone
so you can imagine what the rest of the
cast gonna look like tomorrow just look
big look at the Rays on those swords I'm
sorry
[Music]
oh there's gonna be a lot of chaos right
now in the screen all to lock them in
reopen up kid - and in reality storm you
can use your normal to conjure up other
projectiles on the screen so definitely
muttering right now and kimura down
throwing all these projectiles kind of
it's kind of reminiscent to how cable is
played for Marvel - you know layers on
the screen you know you go for the
office afterwards got keep away - so
that's pretty cool in case you're
wondering this is a three out of five I
believe so okay one one right now oh
three total games sorry yeah three total
games so let's see if we're gonna see it
a little bit more of Gamora or all looks
like we might see a character change I
think I think we're gonna go with the
nove I hope you see know where I played
some tough Spencer if you really want to
bring it back yeah okay that true homage
right and the hands are composting but
what do you have here look Jenna Oh
looks ridiculous looks ridiculous
yeah even I've chance like what what is
that what and combo fiends gonna give us
a treat right now
yo we saw a nineteen male representation
from dark starvation never in a
marvelous series that's not my see Jenna
was a Capcom fighting Jam and he is
making his debut right here evolution
2017 we're about to give a taste of this
character and if it's and if it's kind
of like how he was we might just some
thick layers of offense and starting him
off point he looks so sick these are one
of the cameras for people that follow me
on Twitter I made a wish list and one of
the characters that I wanted was Jetta
and here she is him oh my goodness look
so sick stop stop and he has the
movements from darkness
got a preview of what we're gonna be
you've got to keep in mind guys are
definitely more characters to come in
this game but this is just a nice little
preview calling the goons right now and
I say gravity to get something hit his
licks off now the tag all he missed me
mister knock down to the tag I need a
move list yeah I need a mold list
nothing like he like uses blood like any
looks really good but Ultron's another
character I'm a huge fan of so far as
infinite I character I wanna try more I
like broke on Daniel whoa Oh usual
meters chant watch
none of that you know what salute bad
but that only you're gonna stand on meet
happy birthdays X went down off of that
tag he's stuck in this box and that is
its get boxed in looking like you're
getting moderate for a Barbie so we can
see Tony's face oh yeah that beautiful
yeah Wow overall we can say at this
point just a beautiful preview of what's
to come inside learn